there's a buzz around girls football in
England record crowds watching the
women's game and the success of a
national team that became European
Champions last summer are fueling
excitement and ambition among these 11
and 12 year olds at Barnsley Women's
Football Club
I think it would be a hobby but if I
could I would play for like a big team
but a dream is to be professional but
just to be part of football is going to
be it fine I want to go big play for
England
um but I also just want to enjoy the
game as much as I can and I really do
want to strive to promote the game
Barnsley is part of the football
association's emerging Talent Center
Program 70 centers across England will
give nearly all 8 to 16 year olds access
to professional coaching within an hour
of home there's tons of young female
footballers out there that probably
haven't received such an opportunity
before and there's even more to be
explored and it's ever growing the
environment is more adopting of all
cultures adopting of all play stores
there's more players there's a bigger
pool and it just means that there's more
success
Talent identification is a part of this
but a girl who just wants to play for a
local Club gets the same training as a
potential England star the new structure
of football in England is designed to
give more girls access to the game make
sure they enjoy it more while they're
playing and give more of them the chance
to reach the professional level
meanwhile the England team at the World
Cup is fighting to ensure that when
these girls are eligible for the
national side their pay conditions are
better as well teams like Gloucester
City in tier VI have already seen a
boost in player numbers thanks to
England's success but victory for the
lionesses off the pitch would mean a lot
too the England team are in a dispute
about performance related bonuses
resolving it could be a small step in
closing the huge financial gap between
women and men
he's like a big thing that's just kind
of like the biggest thing about women's
football it's like also like people's
attitudes towards it as well like
they're playing the same game same
minutes everything and it doesn't
compare really does it the success of
women's football has moved the goal
posts financially but the rewards are
still too small and shared by too few
making the Next Generation even more
competitive could make the calls for a
greater share of the commercial spoils
harder to ignore Paul Reese Al Jazeera
Barnsley England
foreign